negli episodi precedenti con cella time
[Musica]
ma chi è questa
parla gesù ricche trovarla
zoppica cisco paniconi di volo
[Musica]
cos'è la felicità
[Applauso]
[Musica]
è dj originals tele così a e lei ex
l'aeroporto di los angeles che si
conclude la nostra compagnia grazie
salvo sei stato un grande compagno di
viaggio
di tre gol tiro questo i due biscotti 16
euro
scusate
duri però aveva un volo diverso dal mio
ad è arrivato a new york in tempo il mio
invece ha fatto otto ore di ritardo
dalla signoria l'aero mi ha fatto otto
ore di ritardo siccome avevamo il volo
diverso sugli arrivato new york tipo
dottore fa sono le 3 del mattino sono
stanco morto dormito per terra sui
tavoli sull'aereo sto morendo vediamo
come la stanza su aree già dentro
ma perché c'è letto così
se questa stanza di merda famiglia si
accende dalla poesia
anche albergo hai preso o dai trovato né
patatina c'è di strano ma è finita la
stanza fa schifo l'aspetto mentre il
flash ecco
sai che il mio falegname con 30 mila
lire la faceva meglio che albergo della
minkia se non altro almeno fuori si sta
per i piloti
dobbiamo portare un piumino cosa di
pesante ma basterà una felpa a
prescindere da questo in video tanto non
sentono il freddo quindi che se ne frega
siamo noi a soffrire youtube era un
lavoro difficile comunque il grigio una
parte si sa matta di scoperta oggi
arrivati ecco letta in specie scritto da
infarto quando che non sappia leggere
quando la piazza e la mia squadra vuol
dire quadrato dov'è il quadrato non si
pone perché qua non sono bravi geometria
se questo
un tappeto persiano questo è il tappeto
imperiale del sultano flash in questo
poi al team con un autentico originale
che i soldi sai quanto mi devi darti a
questo 2 milioni di euro cash 2 milioni
di euro vita evitare che se vuoi solo
questo telefono su due giorni max dal
più piccolo al più grande guarda
1234 scusi sa per caso dove si trova la
pizzeria più vicino mi scusi scusi sono
italiano
abbiamo approfittato ragazzi per andare
al mac che è uno dei musei number one a
new york non è vero è vero passa invece
perché questo non c'è al naso
perché di qua passa molto spesso will
smith
team entrati nel reparto della moda e
non ho idea non avevo idea che esistesse
adesso commenteremo insieme gli outfit
partendo da questo guarda mamma sono
uscito a giocare in giardino mamma mi
sveglio alle 4 del mattino e vado a
controllare cosa c'è nel frigobar da
mamma ho aperto il secondo cassetto
della cucina e un messaggio secolo che
ho provato e poi ragazzi c'è l'ala
americana dopo tutta quella egizia e
l'america non è che abbia tanta storia
infatti è finita questo pezzo sembra un
punto di residenti voci giuro identico
ci sembra veramente in polvere residenti
volo famila zombie xte ragazzi di hold
a me sembra più morgan io l'arte non la
capisco ragazzi per l'amor di dio sono
stupido però mi spieghi tutto libera
schmidt blog non notra no qua ci
arrestano 6 quanto costa sta roba
io non so se sabatini si finisce in
prigione questa roba in lega
lui l'ha lui e io e tua vocal che palle
sti musei no non avrei voluto pagare
questa cosa ma sono costretto a farlo ed
i prossimi tre giorni mi ruberà il cazzo
1.200 dollari non volevo 200 dollari
bastava siamo sui 230 ragazzi vorrei
dire questi soldi delle goderseli sennò
poi domani muore i soldi rimangono lì
perché senso allora magari una serie
dall'inquadratura perchè mi sta toccando
le palle stiamo per mangiare un sushi
epocale a quanto pare allora mi fa
piacere che soria ha bloccato tutto il
cibo e io blog sono il conto meglio dire
tanto cui vorrebbe dire tanto la persona
vediamo un po dato conto da e se come
siamo sui 500 dollari cucina della tip
superiori coach di lorenzo sono nè 420
per i beni cai neve o 40 e hai vinto tu
ma prima di continuare ragazzi mi fermo
un attimino perché siccome abbiamo
pagato un conto così salato sono qui per
introdurvi lo sponsor di oggi
cos'è shark di tenacia che è un servizio
di bpm che vi permette di navigare
online in tutta sicurezza con le vpn
potete fare finta di essi in un altro
posto dove non siete prevedere il
catalogo di netflix di quel posto invece
sono andato alla wai e potevo fare una
casa mia comunque molto facile basta
andare qua schiaccia il tasto cambiare
la posizione degli aerei non servono più
gli aerei e che sarà un basta dice il
tasto search ai ragazzi inoltre
disponibile su tutte quante le
piattaforme abbiamo apple tv playstation
un sacchi ma altra piattaforma e forse
anche il nokia vecchio però questo non
lo so non ho provato ma non finisce qui
con soft shark con un solo abbonamento
potete installare ed utilizzare solo
sharks su quanti dispositivi volete
senza alcun tipo di limite quindi anche
su nokia sempre se funzionava quello non
l'ho provato ancora sul nokia se volete
provarlo vi lascio qui sotto il link per
iscrivervi col codice perché con questo
avete tre mesetti gratis el 83 per cento
di sconto sull'abbonamento e quei
ragazzi finito lo sposo di oggi
ringrazio stò shark e passiamo la linea
a new york siamo vicini all'empire state
boing se voi cercando nel bayern perché
sicamente non lo vediamo
siccome uno degli edifici più alti che
si sono detto beh si vedrà
no non si vede quindi andiamo un po a
tentativi ma guardati quanto cazzo è
alto
c'è pazzesco più credibile
oddio ma ci sono i pdf
vabbè comunque siamo nell empires al
piano terra adesso stiamo salendo
americo lo fanno è sempre più alto
capito poi certo punto ti fa vedere
quello vero
lavorativa di la aspetta eccolo
valentino e
cybill dando mai
tokyo tower questo e tokyo non è bello
ma andiamo a casa dai bassi ora vi
faccio vedere dove sono nato io quella
ma paio di caselle si chiama che sentiva
sta neanche se mi parli pagano loro
voglio sua foto io come siccome tagliato
il naso ma questa è la demo
non so se siete pronti a vedere
l'albergo più bello del mondo tessera è
un pezzetto di legno non è una tessera
va bene
e la porta si apre equa inizia la parte
che c'è un defunto sul balcone niente
abbiamo la vista su central park
benissimo qua c'è che non questo può
perché non abbiamo preso questo hotel
invece quello che abbiamo preso un
tirchio
qua abbiamo il bagno che decisamente più
grosso di quello che abbiamo
dall'altra parte come se non bastasse
c'è tutta un'altra stanza che siccome
questo è il pezzo forte che questo qua
amico mio
e stato un gran piacere ho trovati vivi
ancora 2.000 dollari
next
il minimo fare
chissà che andando in tv